you guys coming out tonight I hope you
enjoy his presentation get something out
of it so couple months ago my dad sent
me over this picture of me on is like
this actually me playing throat I
prostitute a 1200 baud modem on fax 11
and I realized it was the best light
packer crit I could ever boss to half
right so yeah so this talk is about how
coding isn't quite enough to be a good
software developer bunch of other skills
that you need to learn about practice a
long way to really get good at this
friend and see jobs understood this he
was his quote though is this is actually
taking out a bigger goal I'll show you
in a second but he said technology alone
it's not enough and here's the full form
he said it is an apples DNA
is not enough its technology married
with liberal arts married with the
humanities that yields the results that
make our hearts sink and you can best
see Steve's understanding of this
InDesign as it picks out our campus and
by the way I think it by phone because
that's how controlling to the
presentation I'm not like although they
look like a date check to my Nevada
really good promise the November two
thousand jobs purchase an abandoned del
Monte canning factory sixteen about
sixteen acres of Henryville just so
north of Oakland originally it was
supposed to be split into three building
seven offices for the computer
scientists separate offices for the
animators and the Pixar executives but
jobs through the idea Alan said that was
horrible idea instead he made it all
once pics with atrium to Center he knew
the most important function of a company
was the interaction of its employees and
the more opportunity to give them to
have that interaction the better and it
also wasn't good enough just to make
this essential space you have to give
them a reason to go there right so
that's looking what things like mail
boxes meeting rooms the cafeteria coffee
in these places to give them reasons to
have these interactions did a game room
it was all built in shared space he
insisted that the best creations occur
what people from disparate fields are
together to focus on a singular problem
since 1995 that Pixar released Toy Story
did at least 12 films each average is
over 500 million per film John's new
that best innovations didn't come from
just the technology technology alone
isn't enough and it's not all about the
interaction either there's a lot more to
it especially in our field being
software developers so how might be
going through sort of 12 principles and
they're all over the place just things
that I found as I work as a programmer
as I built up empty labs 12 things you
need to be aware of need to get better
at as a software developer to be really
good at your craft and some of these
going to be obvious and some of them
might not be so obvious
so hopefully you find something useful
so the first thing that I mind over and
over again is even the most experienced
developers are afraid of setting
expectations or taking our big estimates
right oh that's rather not happy
everything feel free to like on me every
time
right that's that's what I'm currently
dealing with as like you know kinda
better speaker I think it's because when
you ask people question and your your
plug in the audience like this it's
going to be very hard for me to any sort
of interaction although if you have a
question raise your hand clapping yell
it out still but if you say right you
look at somebody right also under your
left yeah I'm going to nod your head and
you get that positive feedback but I
need to stop back so really as the
estimation is hard kind of like riding a
bike it's something that when you first
looked at really intimidating it's
really scary you're going to fall on
your ass and call times before you get
it right and really it leads to a lot of
project failure addicts of that
estimation the so many types of projects
and fail because of it so an entity
that's right a Hammett front stop that
right now
so another way you can it better
extending expectation is to bring a
client closer to the team what does that
mean well it means checking in with your
client wrong there's some consulting
teams that actually have the client work
they're required to work there with the
developers because it's going to help
with communication and expectation or
I'm gana client with the team also
things like short feedback cycles so as
those building in the labs I realized
one of my goals was to figure out what
is the most transparent way and honest
way over to constructive consultancy to
do consulting work and part of that was
scheduling weekly meetings with the
clients so every Monday more
and a cloth um Doug we talked of this
line whether we did 10 hours of work or
60 hours of work but because we forced
ourself to communicate and set
expectation often it worked out pretty
well and we still do that to this day
always on a weekly basis communicate
with our clients but what's the remote
also with setting expectation using the
right project management tool and I'm
not going to there's one tool that
Sebastian really depends on your project
so people like more the Kanban style
maybe something like Trello or agile Zen
for pivotal tracker and then sometimes
it's better to use something that's more
ticket based like github issues for
example but if the each project have
demands some different strategies
depending on what you're doing okay
number two second thing being mindful of
your engineering background what what do
I mean by that well really when it comes
to people who are analytical who solve
problems when somebody comes to you with
a problem are you the kind of person
that first thinks of all the reasons why
it's going to fail I know that's how I
think I first like to disqualify things
unfortunately that means that people
don't always like to own me their ideas
the only problem with this is that this
kills collaboration all right because
when you're basically doing what someone
comes to an idea and you think through
and the first thing that you do is tell
them here's the five bases it's going to
fail
as it sounds like you're dying
braum diagnosis sounds like criticism
and criticism kills innovation this is
quote from Charles Schwab I've been
getting into more of the business books
and I found this really good quote if I
might association in life meeting with
many and great people in various parts
of the world identify a person what rate
or exalted in a station who did not do
better work and put forth greater effort
under his spirit of approval than would
ever chew under spirit of pretty simple
right
so criticism or diagnosis can kill
innovation so beware beware of getting
diagnosed especially when you're not
asked to especially when somebody is
brainstorming with you
there's this sort of improv practice if
you ever get a chance to do one of these
like business improv practices that by
classes on how
they're great and one of the exercises
that I've seen over over again is this
yes and exercise where you practice
somebody says you know hey I've got an
idea
it's like Reddit meets you know Twitter
and your job is to say yes and it would
be great if in that forum next yes
great if it was blue and white right the
objective is simply to add somebody's
idea when they're brainstorming rather
than to immediately diagnosed or
criticize so when people tell me ideas
and they're strictly ideas and try to
shut up that part of my brain that wants
to tell them why it's a stupid idea
because as the scale and simply play
along with them and help add to the
repeat the other thing that developers
sometimes aren't the greatest that I
find as maybe we're introverts a brutal
shot is giving people our full attention
and something I've definitely been
working on a lot more and when I think
about this I do this half this is
Derek's image I've had the pleasure of
meeting a couple of times to use the
founder of CD Baby and when he's in the
room and somebody is talking to him he
is 120 percent focused well probably
somebody in your life
think of somebody who gives you their
full attention and all of a sudden you
find yourself saying all sorts of things
and spewing all sorts of information
because simply they're attentive right
pay attention listening not judging so
please be mindful of that as well now
you might be shy it's just not sort of
intuitive you do that but it's important
to sort out your rating when people have
an idea they're communicating to you
the other thing is that I need to get
better at especially if I get especially
at a pace when you're working in fast
pace like people do here in New York is
they look really bad habit of
interrupting people as I think I got to
get better on its own so be mindful
granted in your background and a
diagnosing problems when you're not
meant to be diagnosed number three is to
remember that software development is an
art form now I realize when I wrote this
I like to think of it as an art form but
really software development is not an
art form software development is craft
what's the difference between the two
well a craft needs making useful objects
with perhaps decorative touches fine art
means making things purely for their
beauty and yet somehow when good user
interface design comes together with
it comes together with good code we can
somehow build something that we all you
I've seen it I've seen a lots of time to
post when we have a course it has
beautiful design user interface and a
nice jingle and put it all together with
challenges and I could definitely call
it beautiful work and really that's time
your job as a software developer is to
take whatever canvas you're getting no
matter how ugly it is and figure out
some way to turn it into something that
you might call beautiful and I usually
insert at least one branch in my talk
and this is the thumb where I start
talking about how I hit a little pissed
off especially a real community I think
it's gotten better I have appeared as
much these days but there used to be
this whole thing about how products and
creating your own products is the sort
of golden plot the end of the rainbow
that's why we're doing this that's how
we're doing consulting so we can stop
doing that and we can build products and
create a start and that's what we're
trying to do but the bottom line is when
it comes to doing software development
consulting and building somebody else's
product is in many cases more
challenging than creating your own
product and scratching your own pitch
especially if it's a product that you
have no domain
knowledge in that you have no passion
for if you need to break the ground
consulting takes whole other set of
skills to pick up somebody else's domain
to figure out the innovative solutions
to Joel incorrectly right and doing this
shouldn't be seen as any less glamorous
stretching your lah is easy you see it
over and over again in art in our
community where people create all these
project management tools that's what
they do they scratch their own inch
doing that is a lot easier not harder
more challenging to work in domain you
know familiarity with right next and I
want to challenge scrappy crashing
Yeltsin to start your own now I'm a live
in Orlando Florida and I take my kids to
Disneyworld a lot and enjoy taking their
go around I've got a five-year-old
seven-year-old seven-year-old boys and
enter really stoked about them yeah you
know what it's saying about the Navy in
from but I was walking along a Disney
today I saw this quote I thought it
really fit really well you don't build
it yourself you know what the people
want
build it for them as a software 12 or
that's your job is to figure out how you
can take other people's problems and
through your craft create innovative
solutions 2,000 degree report learn how
to delegate and improve the system so
when I first started building the
business I think does this both email
three years ran this this is like the
typical business how about people in the
room you don't have to read it what sort
of business
but what it talks about is that all good
businesses come down to a series of
systems that's why people buy franchises
is because it comes with the manual that
tells you how all the different systems
work all assistants are document right
so really your job as you advance in
your career is to identify these systems
inside your company and figure out that
you can get them to work for you and
then prove the system not to become more
Ali was an employee right it could be
something like touching base with your
clients once a week that was one system
that we put in place that helps our
business grow I also realized as I was
building my consultancy that there is
these people then not only enjoy project
management right alongside the now they
are they're good
only good at organizing things they're
better than you but they actually enjoy
they're called project managers I will
never live without them ever again
because obviously if I start building a
business to do a consulting work I
quickly got overwhelmed the amount of
administrative work that I had to do and
I will never live without a pump we're
doing things like scheduling meetings or
any expectations invoicing organization
and all of a sudden I was saving so much
time per week if I just figured out
force myself what is the system one that
I possibly delegate so really if you
want to be spending more of your day
hooting unless you're day doing that
administrative stuff right figure out
what you can hand off other people house
and there's this sort of program calls
for the engineers to level which looks a
little bit something like this just
because you can do something does not
mean you sure if something is on your
plate and you're capable of it very
often developers will just do it without
a second thought but really is there
somebody else at your team the perhaps
is better than that there's somebody who
enjoys that more than you maybe you can
delegate
I also encourage people to do the math
right let me give you an example so at
this we used to share space with a
company name box there they were a
bigger company rented space from them in
Orlando and Fox Co had a full-time
professional barista on staff which
sounds very lucrative
at first but still until we found very
kind of posh very fancy but until you
start doing the math so let's say that
about 80 people some people need 2 cups
of days so let's on average let's say on
average everybody drinks one cup a day
well they go to coffee they could get up
they have to walk over maybe to go
downstairs to elevator down to Starbucks
if you're Starbucks because I feel arena
they go up and they go back to the seat
try to get back in the zone something
kids even a wasted in all right do the
math that's 1200 minutes that's 20 hours
wasted so if we hired a barista for
eight hours who's probably you know
cheaper than most of our you know
software developers get employed where
can we're actually going to be saving
money if we can keep people in the zone
and we can make the coffee and maybe
even write to them at their desk we'll
be making money so that's just one small
example about doing the math if you had
10 more hours of programming in a week
but just 10 more hours I would easily
pay to have an administrator or an admin
or something to answer your emails now I
know some of you guys about running my
business so not plenty already own
business how does this what's it do for
me right well even if you're a small cog
in a big machine the solution right
isn't always you know hiring somebody
right it all comes back to you as a
earlier trying to figure out if somebody
does a task better than you somebody
enjoys doing something more than you do
right and I was always putting on this
sort of context everything that you do
during the day is either gives you
energy or takes it away and it's your
job so you can be happy to do more of
the stuff that gives you energy and even
among programmers you're going to find
some programmers that love the front-end
bit right maybe they love doing the back
foot plugging it in maybe somebody loves
doing the api's maybe somebody loves
doing e-commerce if you can identify
what people enjoy doing the most and
make sure that they have those tasks
they're going to be happier and probably
enough better and faster others this you
know when you look at all the self-help
books correctly it's talked about things
like first independence and
interdependence that way because
officially working forms is
interdependence first independence of
yourself suspicion that a
self-sufficient and then of all makes
the place where you rely you know lying
on people
delegate to people and count them and
job done alright so we're going to
delegate improve the system the most
valuable employees help improve the
business not just code number five I'm
going to be very popular here for citing
logical prediction all right now we're
finding this a little bit obvious but
others going to be some things in here
you might not have heard it before
continue on inside outside your company
so what can you do inside become well it
any labs we very often have internal
presentations it could be stuff like
that so many presented with Ruby it'll
group and maybe at lunch we bring them
together and everybody teaches everybody
both blah that's pretty popular if we
find a good book that y'all I go through
we basically do one or two chapters a
week and then we all go craft lunch
reach back and discussing chapter
obviously pair programming is a good
habit and that's how people get better
if you got somebody on your team is an
amazing developer and they work by
themselves all the time that is such a
waste or resource right so that's how
that's the easiest way to take those
amazing expert programmers and get to
the siphon or knowledge in such a waste
if you have amazing program
people sort of dispense the knowledge
also one way I think you can get better
inside your company is make sure you're
eating with people inside your nothing
it's scientifically proven that you are
more likely to like somebody if you meet
with them wrong so that's why there's
that book out there we'll never eat
alone I always try to have lunch for
people inside my company and we also do
a tradition on a Friday 3:00 Friday we
cater lunch times we'll do an internal
to presentation sometimes we'll just
hang out and it's those types of things
that really build your team together
Oh screencasts so we have a culture
around stray cats
obviously I'm a huge screen cast guy um
but what we started doing very early on
in our consultancy is every Friday we
would create a not only not only would
we deploy our work to the stadium server
to show our client but we would also
create a five-minute screencast to show
them what we've done because the people
you're creating software for they're
busy people to the odds of them like
figuring you trying out that feature
it's like 10 levels deep that you have
to have two users accounts that you work
on that they're really going to test it
all out that you really want and
somewhat knee them to is closer to nil
what if you create a find it screencast
and show it to them they're going to
watch it so we started doing that with
our clients and they absolutely love it
it's not only will they watch the
screencast but we'll send it to five
other people's and if their investors
keep it around I think they might use it
as documentation to do you want to use
the system and what's cool about this
pilot screencast go in first of all I
wouldn't also say that we use Jane Jane
has an amazing tool for doing this and I
would never use any other tool Jane is
sort of like Twitter for screencasts it
forces you to only keep things to five
minutes and there's no editing no
editing allowed because you know
engineers sometimes were perfectionist
and you want to get the screencast just
right and you might edit it by the
screencast for an hour and we still
allow that to use Jing do one take
shouldn't take you longer than 20
minutes we're all together it all set up
go but what's also cool about these 5
min screencast is that every other
Friday after lunch we get together and
every team has to submit one of their
screencasts they might have showed it to
a client and in every company we watch
all these trinkets and that's how we get
to stay on the same page we have a team
of now 33 people and there's no way I
was going to be aware what everyone's
working on but we put together a bunch
of these five of its trade cats and
there's so much fun to watch the group
and you get to go home everyone gets to
go home on Friday with a good feeling
that they know what's going on the
company and they might know who to go to
whether you'd implement a feature is
they saw the other guy worked on that
the project's you don't do big fast so
that's worked out really well and I
realized to be a lot of fun watching
your screencast on price also nobody
does retrospectives enough when it comes
to
as I accompany no I've never got a
company that isn't enough and while in
case you're not familiar retrospective
simply means taking the time after a
project is done to have a meeting and
say okay what went well and what didn't
go well and how can you make sure it's
we do all your better next time
no company spends at that time doing
that if you get scheduled time to do
that you know you're going to learn a
lot great way to learn
but right after you don't the project
taking time to figure out how you can
improve okay so that's learning in say
to come let me ask you company some of
these are obvious it was a website
company also I do the Ruby five podcast
anybody else very fun help you guys so
this is a twice weekly groovy team
podcast where we cover the latest users
Ruby and rails community and you know
something that you can listen to when
you know you're doing larger e community
to work well on washing your cat
whatever also horse Woodcock's is going
to beat ups like this are pretty useful
I guess EE great city to get access to
all great educational
obviously users groups like this one
it's fantastic our three beaches here
here this lawns are great you guys have
access to so many resources here events
like our camp where you sort of cross
pollinate between different disciplines
and let's just well so after learning
number 6 would be stay out of your
comfort zone I added this life this
presentation recently because it is
really important to stay at your comfort
zone what do I mean by that well you're
going to go over to work tomorrow and
you're going to have a task list all
right
bunch of tasks in front of you some of
them are going to be easy as some are
going to be difficult and it doesn't
difficult you're probably the being a
little scary
and they'd even risky but at the end of
the week looking back which tasks do you
think you will learn the most from the
easy ones or the difficult scary ones
probably difficult scary ones the
difficult tasks are usually the ones
that you keep alternate lets you keep on
improving so you really need to keep
that in mind the problem is that as
humans we naturally gravitate towards
the easy good example this is the email
track right people you know comes to
email email such an easy way to get that
quick feeling of gratification of
getting stuff done if that google squirt
of adornments every time you go through
your answering email
as well as easy tasks that you can do I
feel productive but I really learning
anything really so you want to learn the
most when you work right stay out of
your comfort zone understand that is
scary
risky tasks that feel uncomfortable that
give you art you'd probably give you the
most reward and you're going to learn
the most from so I'm seven make friends
and build relationships oh happy story
really individuals interactions over
processes and tools imagine Festo and
then I don't have to tell you about it
you know obviously it was good lots of
scientific psychology studies how more
friendships you have and more support
you have the people around you here you
go beat the half you're going to be the
better part you're going to do right so
it kind of begs the question how much
time do you spend at work nurturing
friendships it goes what it comes down
to it one way you can make everyone
around you better it's actually to
become a better friend if you want to be
more valuable employee maybe you need to
be that support system so as people
don't value that enough your value :
must code but really there's a lot to be
said for solidifying relation
people you work with because if you have
those friendships you're going to be
happier they're gonna be happier and you
guys can do better work together the way
you can make the Ruby community bed
early New York City your baby's better
is to make more friends lots of people
here you probably don't know I don't I'm
not going to thank you all stand up and
meet your neighbors don't work
proposition
people so this is a fun some people
wonder like them but wait I don't what
am i what am I gonna say hello my name
is there's there's a secret to talking
and people and that is simply this
people love talking about those such as
all you have to know right so you
produce yourselves right it seems
obvious but you introduce yourself I'm
great I love away from new something out
to do and be surprised people love
result I always try to challenge people
so these talks
it's a goal so if I were to give you
guys a cool or a mission after this talk
is over your your mission is to meet
five new people right here
maybe you'll connect to somebody maybe
give you a job you know so that's the
recipient may friends relationships
don't worry yet better I have no idea
why this Russian eunuch
but it's whatever is that our Russian or
Soviet unicorns reactors that's what I
thought of the solo immediately I see
that promise okay I like yeah yeah don't
be afraid to ask for help especially if
you important using you um so this comes
down to really okay there you are
working your task you're working on it
fest again it's going to take me two
hours to get done yeah yeah you're going
to trying to go over two hours you ask
for help no you're only two hours in so
now we're hours later you're still
working on it
and that's you're already over should
you keep going to finish it you know
he's probably out eight hours later
you're like I'm going to do it up
[ __ ] gonna do it I'm sure you all
didn't hear so like what would have
happened if you couldn't ask for help
tremors obviously right maybe you would
have done three hours but there's this
confidence thing
we get involved right of course it's
better to fail after two hours and fill
over eight hours if it takes you eight
hours to do something maybe you're doing
it wrong maybe there's something you
don't know it's totally natural that
once you committed doing something
you're going to do it yourself that
you're a lot less likely to ask for help
or even give up let me show you an
example let's say that somewhere in the
world there's this country that needs
help but it has an evil dictator well
we'll call it the country will conquer
Pakistan and I'm gonna steal dictator
looks similar to that logic and he is
suppressing if people doing all sorts
portable things so well let's okay send
the troops out there we go and it's not
going so good it feels like blues do we
consider giving up now where we put it
all we team up in DoubleDown must be
recorded
we're trying to win it's much harder to
ask for help and defeat now I wasn't
trying to make
during their but if you thought I was
trying to make it you think that's cool
that I was right it's just human nature
that what's you're involved in sometimes
that you don't give up I try to tell the
developers that work for me um give
yourself 30 minutes if you have a
problem it's been difficult it's giving
you a hard time
don't struggle with it from one hundred
and thirty minutes you're yourself that
time without and you can't figure it out
ask for help and as I said earlier
there's something taking too much time
you're probably doing wrong so who do
you ask
can you imagine a co-worker and me my
ask somebody to care program with you
maybe it could be Twitter if your user
group family lists your code crew right
guys careers for each other right ask
them ask each other
you can also pre on the problems which I
try to try to do at any labs I encourage
my employees to look at their task list
identify the beginning of the me which
tasks are going to be the most risky the
most challenging and maybe ask at that
point who wants to pair with me on this
task so preempt the issues by
identifying harder tasks that may be
pairing or maybe you just having a
meeting to flush out the architecture
also every night and find like nobody
told me how long this talk was supposed
to be over dessert timer goes to end
this fun
for about 2/3 is not a number 9 to get
better at being a software developer
literature eliminate distractions can
get in the zone
but you know we're all trying to do that
we all need to eliminate distractions
but also it's important to understand
that it's not natural people talk to
about 100 percent of the time this is
something I have to tell my employees
like every month or to me that's really
important that they understand that
optimally you're having at work about to
make % fun doing whatever at about 80%
productivity that's probably about right
so the other thing that kills me as
somebody like oh I never Ange to be a
founder of a company but here I am and
then
but what kills me more than anything is
when I walk over to it's over or
designer and I go over to tell them
something and I look out with your
screen and they close before part of me
just dies but I see that because there
is nothing worse than having to like
fear that Austin interview frame-off so
I just how is every like one that is
that I don't care what you're doing I
don't expect you to work on your percent
at the time go on Facebook watch videos
have fun as long as you're beating
client or customer is expectation I
don't care it yes but yeah it's
important it's also important to bet
they also weren't invited to give people
opportunities to take breaks do they
have like ping-pong mom is great we do
things
so those opposite properties are great
also to sort of stay in the zone sides
giving yourself breaks obviously it was
obvious turning off communication
Iceland you get better at first ring
emails writing on Twitter during em so
that you can really focus on your work
asynchronous communication of leveraging
that right way so it's not me it means
like when I need to talk to somebody to
tell them something I say okay how
urgent is this okay we have on their
shoulder at cetera I am is it even that
port no probably not
okay I'll send them an email so try to
be really conscious about communication
like that if you don't need to interrupt
somebody and you can tell they're over
in there in the zone or conse down there
of them that goes for anybody
also I like alternative workspaces I
kind of feel to buy the same Space
Marine all weekend like it that's why
you know that if you laughs we let
people
if you want to work alone Tuesday
Thursdays please do or a coffee shop we
also provide places around work like you
know that got couches in hammocks and
over again that's not by all as I spoke
but I love post-it notes there's
something about writing down physically
like a task list that keeps me more
productive
having that the beginning of they
spending time right now everybody get
done and then taking the time to better
their to prioritize I've seen it work
really effectively I have to be
accomplished right there stuff like that
academic or since I'm going on tell us
also there's like systems for saying
more productive like Pomodoro yeah check
it out now check it out it's basically
if you assign a retake
20 minutes 10 minutes was it somebody
knows it
25 minutes that bottom is off all right
so page your timer so you clean up it if
you're focused positive that you're
doing something else reading about
having fun you go back and focus that's
all
so that's larger than a distraction
again Janome and I want to know some of
these definis yeah I've heard of it but
I swear like next time you know I
started coming and we have to the money
just started I think I'm going to buy
everybody like $200 noise-canceling Bose
headphones right so people can you know
are going to be more likely same zone I
can distract like and I want to see like
how quickly I'm going to get back the
money that I spent on was really
expensive headphones
I'm going to get back your money really
quick opportunity number 10 the most
complex solution is really the best
solution
I hate to say it sometimes a solution is
WordPress phrase so um right so it
allowed me by that I mean that the l
word press fit out-of-the-box solution
it does a lot for a lot of people it's a
good content management solution and you
should over engineer as developers were
really good over engineering which is a
million times in plank code school echo
school we said we realize that a word
every lots of products in the next few
years right so let's create a billing
systems at the time it wasn't anything
that it was exactly the way we wanted to
let's create a recurring billing system
yeah do it and we'll be like multi
tenant thing so like everything create a
product it'll use that one billing
system how many tenants do you think our
billing system [ __ ] won the last
three years because you're like yeah
we'll he's over into God again
so that was that was horrible for
engineers so we're like yeah we'll Stu
it'll be more complex but eventually
it'll need it he's assembly so yeah be
mindful of that as well the other thing
you can do to be a better software
developer is communicate better than
everyone else on such quote from that I
work with creating quality software's
percent codon y % communication where Y
is greater than X so it comes down to
it's about communications which is why
sometimes people come up to me and they
say it's code school going to replace
the colleges and computer science
program someday I just know you don't
even get it
not at all because really what you get
when you're go in one of those programs
or you go to you know Flatiron school
around here or you know general assembly
stuff is you learn the communication
part which is just as important as the
goading for this presentation right so
really so how can you communicate better
or less you're like them well well first
can we mention this is really
interesting thing rework so great look
what's interesting in there is they say
hi great writers if you've got two
candidates that are applying for the
same job
look at their writing skills and see who
writes better because great writers know
how to communicate they know
understand they can put themselves into
someone else's shoes fear right is a
clear sign is a sign of clear thinking
so if you can communicate more
effectively as a writer you're going to
be a more effective worker they knew
that so how you communicate more
effectively well you can do things like
of course you know leverage the right
project management tool make sure you're
using something that works well on your
team also force yourself to communicate
like I talked about earlier put
processes in place that force you on a
weekly basis to do things like check in
with your client chicken with your team
ask things how things are going do
project planning do estimation even if
you don't have a client do best
information for the sake of doing it so
you'll have track right also probably
the most useful thing if you take
anything away from this talk it's use
things like Jing now I used to say
sketch it was awesome until it kind of
quiet about Evernote and then I think it
kind of sucks for a couple reasons um
I'll go in with but recently if you're
on a Mac I really dig model snap it does
the same sort of
thing basically where you know you take
a screenshot you can handle change if
you're on the PC just use Jing Jing
allows you to do both the screen sharing
screen casts and the screenshots so when
it comes down to it all I'm trying to
say is communicate through images and
video and not Wars if there's any way
through videos and images to do is you
shouldn't end to what was pretty amazing
sometimes sometimes we'll train our
clients you should train all your
clients and all your project managers
and anybody who is to communicate with
you expectations or QA they should all
know how to use Jing they should all
know how to use screen casts because I
can tell you about that first time that
a client seppius great cast they were
like look see how the system when you do
this this happens we need to fix this my
work here is done
Drago all right so if you can train the
people around you to better communicate
using tools like screams you know the
screenshots and video is going to be
really innovative if you're getting a
better your job you're going to be the
low so if you can
with people around you and screenshots
and screencasts you're gonna be the most
valuable employee easily very quickly
you're going to get better than
everybody else
all right number 12 is the last one
whole thing you can do as suffered over
is to try to understand what will bring
you happiness what gets you gives you
energy the other cut downs where people
aren't usually good at choosing what
will make them happy it's not money
there's no lots of studies that prove in
people with lottery you're later just as
happy as anyone else it's not pain
that's going to make you happy or should
I say sup Fame of somebody around me
he's not as famous lose yeah it's not
only right so it's not Fame it's not
money it's not only the code under tools
better domaine right technology alone is
not about what I think it comes down to
is doing meaningful work and how do you
mean forward well everyone wants to be a
part of something bigger than themselves
now I'll give you ten or
I'll give you 11 ways you can do more of
meaningful work we find more meaning in
the work that you do can you do things
like set expectation I pull of your
engineering program understand that
software development to crop learn how
to delegate better eating you are inside
outside good company stay out of your
comfort zone remember the most
uncomfortable and scary tasks or very
often going to be the ones you will
learn the most from and you grow those
from make friends and build
relationships because really it's those
relationships that will also bring you
happiness don't be afraid to ask for
help and look out for Soviet uniform
learn to win the distractions and get in
the zone realize that the solution
sometimes is word growth communicate
better
and lastly communicate
yells really you can help you do better
work each of these can help the people
around you do better work at each of
these can create more meaning and the
work that you do and hopefully bring you
a little more happiness that's my talk